we've already hit McDonald's we've
already hit In-N-Out literally in- and
out the coers in and out every time
you're we just can't seem to nail a
custers around
s hey gang want to let you know that
fairity are good buddies they craft
clothes that feel as good as a day at
the beach started by twin brothers not
Randy and I but Alex and Mike in 2013
the brand is now celebrating 10 years of
what they're all about making things
that last caring for people in the
planet and always spreading Good Vibes
sure they're backed by their guarantee
of quality they stand behind everything
they make 100% fairity is giving all
dumb people Town listers an amazing deal
that's 20% off your order head Toof
fairity brand.com DPT use the code DPT a
check out for 20% off your order that's
F AER T brand.com
DPT thank you so much to our sponsor
Skylight calendar the Skylight calendar
is a super easy to set up and use
calendar for your home it works by
syncing events from already existing
calendars that you have including Google
Outlook Apple calendars you can also add
events directly through the touchcreen
or with the free Skylight mobile app and
as a special limited time offer for our
listeners you get $15 off your purchase
of a skylight calendar when you go to
Skylight cal.com DPT so to get $15 off
your purchase of a skylight calendar
just go to Skylight cal.com
DPT that's SK y l i ght c a l
/dp hey guys welcome to another episode
of people Town population population Tes
Shane Tes hi my friend hi Shane Shane
Tes the third uh it's actually it is
Shane Tes the 5ifth actually oh wow so
it's a long line of Shane
tourism Is that real or a bit it feels
real this how we this how we getac we
get him to stay conspiracy we will
reveal at the end hate when your comedy
friend says something that you're really
interested in but you don't know if
you're an idiot but because they're so
good cuz he's so good and also you know
when also when you know you're about to
say something interesting to your friend
and you have to tell them you have to
pre be like this is not a bit if you're
not in bit mode and you're like you
[__] know Ian carmel's dad was a
c wait but like Dan don't you know that
like your sneakiest and funniest com
friends will will say this is not a bit
when when they are about to do a bit
they will say that you like I can't
trust you I can't trust you at all
I'm so happy to Wings Dan
this does one of you have a cat cuz I
can't be here really you guys the best
though is when you know it's a bed and
you're with civilians and they're so
awkward by the fact that like they don't
know they think you really did kick your
own friend out of the bar yeah why don't
you [__] it he's our friend weird a bit
we're doing anyway all right here's the
beauty so uh we have Shane here from
from New York I'm very excited we have
him here cuz the world is so dumb that
we just need to make sense of it and we
have three stories three stories that
get sent To Us by our awesome fans and
we will try and make sense of it Jay you
have the first story let's jum it right
now and then we'll talk about Shane's
awesome special at the top have you guys
are from St Louis right yes yeah I have
a St Louis story for you oh snap we'll
do that in the top of segment let's do
it okay uh this is sent in by carlen
mcder sheb carlen thank you uh I'll do
the headline she is her she sends great
stories to us she's out there we have
like our dumb stringers out there
[__] they're out there on dumb boots
on the ground uh man claiming and I
won't tell you how much money he wants
to get good for back injury posts
pictures hanging upside down on zipwire
okay you can't sue people wait isn't
that therapeutic it is it is it isn't
that the thing isn't that the thing is
have you ever tried one of those Shane
where you know like down upside down
it's like a giant C that you flip upside
down and then you're hanging how do you
get back stra to it stra you're strapped
to it Hannibal Lector style stor style
flipped it upside down there's it's
called like the inversion technique or
something like that you know that's the
thing too they say like there's a time
in your like the last time you say let's
pretend and like really mean it uh
you'll do it like again when you have
kids but like as for yourself that you
never know the last time you're going to
say Let's Pretend yeah there also you
don't know the last time you're going to
hang upside down for fun I right as a
someone who's been curvy their whole
life it has never been for me to be that
is truly but I so maybe you ended at 5
maybe at 5 was your last time if I'm
being generous being generous yeah have
you ever done it have you ever done a
zipline no have you what am I one of
these [__] outside of the Rio I
think I'm doing plug but I might be
doing a show in kauwaii next year you
should and and I love Kawaii I've been
there a couple times but I will I would
100% zip with your back have you that I
love I have you did a zipline has
anybody parasailed as well I've Paras
sailed and zipline up in Tahoe there is
this great sort of high ropes course
thing and I was like even though you're
hooked into a thing I was terrified to
walk across this thing but then you ZIP
down and you can like see the whole cuz
it's up you can like is it fun when
you're zipping oh my God it's the
greatest thing in the world when you're
Z walking across you walk AC even like
you walk I'm nervous about Heights and
stuff this was great because the more I
did it the better you got and the more
you're kind of like well if I just fall
you when the more you do it the
better more comfortable you get so like
there's you walk across like super
narrow things and there's ground on the
it's like wire walking at at times it's
crazy you I mean you when you tour with
Bert you guys haven't gotten into some
weird [__] that you're like why am I
doing like come on let's go do this we
do plenty of weird didn't you guys like
like you got in the third quarter of a
Nebraska
game like that's how crazy it is two
interceptions they're like all right who
still has lineman who has eligibility
who has we're doing a bit but you guys
have done some wild [__] we do some wild
[__] but like I I for sure I'm the
person in the party who's like I think
all like I'm like I don't want to be the
cliff jumper I don't want anything right
that results in injury could like if I
am laid up for 3 weeks it'll be
financially different oh you know what I
did zipline I zip lined in Vegas I did
the Fremont Street zipline so that's and
then like yeah it's really fun like a
white trash cover band is playing heart
attack she's
my I'm
like it's it's worth it's fun let's go
to the Golden Horseshoe play some
cracks why do you always drag me here oh
my God look at that divorce
happening someone set up an IV for me
all right uh let's get into this so he
says I have a back
injury so he's CLA he wants a big payout
and we'll guess later what that is of
him hanging ups fake back injuries was
caught out was CAU after uh he posted
photos of himself hanging upside down
from a zip wire on a holiday in Mexico
so by the way you can do it if you're
I'm I'm saying this is bad you should
never try and defraud people out of
money that's awful but if this guy is
going to do it you can go to the zipline
you can you can take pictures of it
don't post the photos I don't so stupid
what yeah how good was that photo though
it had to be so good I'll show it to you
to post it you know
are these well I'll keep going cuz I I
got I'm going to have a lot of questions
whenever you want his name is Frank f r
NC fank fank fank
fank Frank
gr Frank Frank and gr Frank and Frank
which is basically just grun he's
basically just gr Kieran novitz I'm do
you want to guess how old he is now
years old Dan since 54 I think I it's a
young man's move uh I'm going to say
mid-30s
39 39 get your answers in one of you is
kind of close for rank kovitz is 45
years old there you go no better that is
he's also like he's the type of guy
who's like 45 and he's like I wish I was
retired
Frank we've talked about this I had to
have a conversation with my mother and I
said Mom you need to understand whatever
you say on Facebook you are saying to a
gymnasium full of people that you don't
even know are in the room and you are
inviting them speak back to you this
dudee is even 45 this is too young but
he's doing that thing where he thinks
who's going to see it it's my thing we
are used to like if you put it out there
it's gone he's too stupid you know's
going to see it the insurance company
that doesn't money on yourone salary to
hunt down your [__] that is waiting for
you to screw up waiting for you to screw
up to not pay you said he suffered
whiplash injuries and a prolapse disc I
wish it was an anus when a car drove
into the back of him on August 2016 not
denying that that didn't happen or he
didn't feel that way okay so he claimed
a certain amount of money that he wanted
compensation for the injuries which he
said required surgery in 2019 but a
judge found there was no way to link the
Whiplash and prolapse disc connected to
the car accident so already they're like
it's not happening it's over he's from
lakenham Norfolk which I'm going guess
because it is in pound so I'm guessing
this is England was found to have lied
about the extent of his injuries and
loss of earnings to the point of
criminal dishonesty you guys meet a dumb
Englishman are you just puzzled yeah cuz
like your accent says you're smarter
than you are okay this is the dumb thing
I feel like you probably covered before
unless it's like a super deep like in it
right like a [__] got like a laborers
tone for their voice like this guy is
definitely [__] you're like okay uh
Damian roor from Clyde and Co LLP who
investigated the case this guy's just
lying in the weed to be an investigator
Damen R Dam from Clyde from Clyde and Co
trying to fake injuries over a prolonged
period is much more difficult in today's
connected world it's what we're saying
we all know so much social media CCTV
and the ability to easily take
surveillance footage whoa now this guy's
now you're stepping the line now you're
like I lived in his in his backyard for
mon ability to easily you know go
through garage CCTV like how much access
do you have to closed circuit televis
like I mean if there's but he's talking
about like if you do something somewhere
and there's like a security camera from
a business or or can they tap into your
ring footage yeah like if you have a
ring dance I'll tell you like my
information is out there for anyone to
grab like well maybe if they're saying
part of the investigation to see do you
know there's a whole genre on YouTube of
people just of just scary ring cam
videos oh yeah like showing up to
people's house in the did you see the
one of the snake no there's this guy
just goes up to Rings a doorbell and a
snake just comes down from like a rapor
and just [__] like right on his face
yeah yeah so hot like
crazy I love it what's that call a scare
boner what's that
snake's what's that snake's problem in a
medical examination over a year later in
September 2017 kovitz alleged that the
Whiplash in a prst stopped him from
working for 3 months in 2016 he also
alleged it stopped him from starting a
new job and could not clean garden go to
the gym play football or swim or zipline
a private MRI he didn't say could
zipline that's his medical he didn't say
he couldn't zip so here it is a private
MRI in Budapest Hungary that's where you
go in Europe when you want someone to
like should I get the MRI is quite a
trip Lanier no private I mean are you I
pay for this international trip they
recommended he next but are you hip to
how many people are going to Europe to
get medical procedures oh I'm sure is
this a real thing real guarant nose jobs
uh huge uh hair uh transplant like sex
change operations in Sweden they're
doing is that for real I don't why you
guys keep bitting me think I know I know
I'm biting hard I'm biting hard I know D
the 70s that was a big thing going to no
but I mean there are people it's like I
think all in you can go to Turkey to get
rhinoplasty you're there for 2 weeks
flights Hotel hospital and procedure and
it's like 4K like 5K I mean it's 10K
just to do it in the states yes and then
a lot of men are going to go to Turkey
mhm for 4K get Rhinoplasty do you want
it do you I don't want it but I would
like to see turkey I would like to see
some of the world and if it's going to
cost me I'm not even getting surgery so
I think we could knock that's a pretty
big expense everywhere I might be able
to get there for there people doing
their teeth there's men doing you know
the that's not a transplant anymore but
like you know follicle uh replacement we
have friends that have done that here in
the states I love that it's become such
a thing that dudes are just like yeah I
got my [__] it's cool ownership is
there now yes I tried to do it I wasn't
a candidate for it why would a candidate
it was just the hair that they have to
take from here they were just afraid
that it was thinning and uh they were
like you could run into a deal where we
do this and then you start losing it the
other way and you're then we have to you
would just go back to shaving is perfect
yet it's not the I you remember 2013
2014 I I can grow hair out to like you
be like that dude is not bald but it's
just it thins enough for me that I'm
like I'd rather just [__]
it what you said the ownership of like
men being like I don't going to shave it
and not care or yes I got hair
restoration but anyway there's a lot of
people going overseas you think like
women are like like a guy with real hair
or fake hair do you think they I don't
think they care I don't think a woman
care I mean you can see it Jiggles
differently hair yeah when they jog when
you jog it's a lot different it's firm
on some gu less firm on like really what
it is is it it doesn't look natural to
their body frame yeah exactly but but
but anyways it is weird that he went to
hug you just for an MRI I mean and if
you have too much hair it gives you back
problems uh all right a private okay
Clyde company working on behalf of AXA
UK discovered social media post painting
a very different picture to that of the
injured man the post from a Mexico
holiday in February all over the place
2019 this is 6 months before his neck
surgery dummy uh what say this again I'm
sorry I missed a little bit so Clyde and
Company where this other guy works Pi
really
firm they worked on behalf of AXA UK
which is the insurance comp the
insurance compan this when I need charts
they discovered social media posts
painting a very different picture of
that injured man who was supposed to
have as you know decreed by this private
MRI place in Budapest surg Hungary
surgery in 2019 on his neck and back so
six months before that 6 months before
his surgery they saw him hanging upside
down from a rope ziplining and climbing
ropes and ladders which I don't think
you can do I was with him until the
climbing ropes and ladders cuz I was
like if you're just hooked to something
and you're flowing L could be maybe that
doesn't hurt I mean i' I've dealt with a
back injury like the back half of this
year Dan you're going to love his
response when he was confronted with the
evidence in Norwich County Court Norfolk
on February 6th of this year his
response was he was told he may not be
able to engage in sports after the
surgery mhm so he wants to enjoy them
one last time yeah
I mean it sucks because that's a little
grifty I like that that's the lie that's
the lie you tell yourself like that's
the lie to tell yourself justifies
stealing that's what you tell your
fiance when you're like look I had to
have sex one time with the stripper
before because after this I'm not going
to be able to I want to know what I'm
not going to be missing I'm going to
rehab tomorrow I need to do this CRA
right now I will propes this by saying
he you you you have to shut it down if
you're in litigation to prove something
mhm however there could be a world where
he's like yeah I went and did that it
hurt like [__] hell because it hurts
to do this but if I'm not going to be
able to do it at all afterwards I went
and did it and like bit through the
[__] pain and did it but the problem
is is the surgery make yeah I did it and
it hurt but what hurt more is when your
carelessness as a company
hir who here hasn't by the way or say
like a Lal Hut
I was going to say the other great
lawyer that Phil Hartman played was the
caveman froz Cav Frozen cavan I know I'm
just a c I don't know if little goblins
got into your F machine I don't
understand your modern ziplining I
understand your
ways rest District Judge Jacqueline
ragit stated that there was no proof
that
his stated there was no proof that his
injuries and surgery were related to the
2016 accident judge ragit uh ruled that
the claim as fundamentally dishonest and
was ordered to repay AXA UK their legal
cost estimated at a cost of
what pound this we we're not guessing
what he asked for we're not guessing
what he asked for but you're going to
find out right now we'll do that at the
end we're going to find out right now
how much he ordered to ,000 £5,000 £
35,000 27,000 how about 122,000 there
you go okay
still a lot of money a lot of money it
is a lot of money uh Dam uh Damen roor
said it's important to realize that had
he been successful Mr kenova's crime
would have would not have been
victimless honest motorists around the
country would ultimately have paid the
cost of his fraud mean now now I'm on
the GU side you to hike up your [__]
price now I'm on the they're going to
hike it up anyway everybody's going to
have to pay for this anyway really if
this if this ziplining lunatic hadn't
gotten
$200,000 you wouldn't be paying an extra
eight bucks a month oh wait I'm sorry
this 12,000 that he repaid is now going
to save everybody money I agree yeah
maybe that's the biggest crime that this
guy did in this whole situation which
was make the insurance company seem like
a victim right you know what I'm saying
like don't don't don't do that all you
have to do is not post a [__] I'll
show you the photos you're going to love
him Chris Walsh commercial claims
director at AXA UK said insurance fraud
is a serious crime which has
significant consequences for frauders
and I'm going to show you all these my
God I can't you're going to so he's oh
good oh yeah I
mean my
man hey my I think he's like you say
bolting dude yeah you're not hurting
you're fine no man he's hot doging is
what by the way okay doing this by the
way when I said I went down a zipline
not in my wildest dreams would I ever
hung hang upside down down the these
pictures look like an ad for how
successful back surgery can be like like
this is this is all a flex L will stand
like that with a may cause death
diarrhea and but it will enlarge going
this dude is like also he's like pretty
fit looking yeah you know like many
straps on you it's kind of pulling all
yeah your clothes over all your worst
Parts like I literally think there are
friends in his life who are like how's
your insurance fraud thing going yeah
like they know it it's that they know
that that's
doing and he's the kind of person who
would post that conversation on Twitter
how's your
insurance I'm still working through that
still working through you uh still
pretending to be an orphan at Christmas
to get
socks all right so I remember the number
Dan don't look how much did he ask for
what was his claim that he asked for in
pounds what do you think to help him I
mean considering the G this man has had
balls
it's at least um I'm somewhere in the
million I'm a million bucks I he's so
crazy milon crazy million pound guy I
say 350,000 lb I'm going to go 250,000
lb 2 all right get your answers in this
is end of story one and then we'll get
rolling into story two uh I think his
his strategy you guys will be surprised
to find out was let me make it low and
let me make it like something that won't
make a quote unquote dent
he probably figured out what's the most
oh no no
22,000 22,000 does he have to pay back
12 12 so he lost 12 which is about
$155,000 I think based on he's got like
a real gambler's mindset of like this is
not what I'm not winning cuz I yeah
actually I'm up I'm actually up if you
look at it like actually I'm up the bank
set and I'll have to talk to them
because they should have charged me for
that drink at the bar cuz that wasn't a
that wasn't a gambling drink technically
but if I do a SLI and fall outside of
7 I want be if you don't count the tips
I've given out like that's just giving
out tips I'm actually up you know
staying at my fol I'm not paying rent he
shows up at a party with like a fake
cast on his arms he walked in and he's
like we're back baby or he yeah baby or
he's like I have been I have been
tipping at 14% for for the last if you
add up all that that I'm still ahead
10,000 they don't come to my door when I
order GrubHub so I don't
yeah like so that's I know they're not
coming up that by the gate and you're
going tell me this Uber driver is going
to remember my face as many times as he
loops around I love he can rap me all he
wants I don't this heless is basically
free yeah these little things that
chipotle I can take the hot sauces and
build a right you can take them you can
take them you can take them all right
there you go Story one down in the books
when we come back we're going to hear
about Shane's awesome special that you
guys all have to check out and his
podcast podcast which is right here on
all things comedy we'll do all that and
then find out what we have going on
right after break it's D people town
Shane
[Music]
Torres hey guys welcome back to the Sho
welcome back everybody uh before we get
into what chain has going on uh we got
to let you guys know we'll let you know
what's happening for us uh Hey end of
the year uh or beginning of the new year
we're going to be in Portland Oregon at
Helium on the 4th and then on the fifth
we're going to be in Seattle at the
crocodile uh in February at the very
beginning we're going to be back in
Denver at Comedy Works South we were
talking about this of the show one of
our favorite clubs let's sell these
shows out we did so well there last time
we loved it so much we have new material
it's going to be so much fun that's
great and then on the fifth we're going
to do a very special uh tag it at Largo
I believe hopefully Jud Appel will be on
that show maybe John malany we'll see
it's going to be really fun tag it there
Heavy Hitters Zack Alanis I think will
be on that show Good Times that's it
Largo on the 5th and then we're in
Detroit at the beginning of uh March and
then Minneapolis the beginning of April
and uh Mo Tower Mo Tower with you see
amoun that yet I mean we're saying it
we're saying it we don't give a [__]
we're saying it they said we could I
think we could announce and then uh a
real Frank Kiran noit with it
yeah it's just on this podcast who's
going to hear it uh so good stuff all
the way around and then hey if this coms
out before the very end of the year uh
we participated in road on the Kevin
Hart uh Keenan Thompson end of the year
special on peacock which we wrote a
sketch for Dan to do that an appearance
that he was so God f was craing up so
much here how you know Dan was great on
the show I walk out to go do like a pre-
interview with Jim Kramer from Mad Money
and I'm talking to the casting people
from there and they're like that Dan
vankirk is so great isn't he and I'm
like and you're like it's Daniel it's
Daniel or whatever they said and I was
like I you're talking to someone who
agrees like I was like no keep calling
him Dan because if Dan doesn't have
somebody to correct then he's not Dan
Dan won't be feeling alive I don't want
him to get it the way say that to Kevin
Hart it's
Daniel I would would call him little Kev
does he want to be called little Kev I
mean he's got a show us to go by little
Kev he's as big as a get so anyway it
was super fun that's going to be on
peock on the 26th but it's probably
still going to be up for a long time it
was so much fun so much fun hey let's
get into Shane special coming out now
people can watch it December 10th uh M
and my YouTube channel and ber Cher's
YouTube channel B produced it yes it's
called the blue-eyed Mexican um God damn
it yeah uh I really wanted something
that would it's based on Google ability
like the blueeyed
Mexican if I didn't know you if I didn't
know how funny you were and you're such
a good standup I'm I'm in thank you like
it's like I thought well like I'm from
Texas Willie Nelson is the redheaded
stranger right dream is to tour with him
oh God [__] the redheaded you know the
redheaded stranger and the blue-eyed
Mexican that to me sounds like a movie
that like in 1979 Robert Redford
directed it Clint Eastwood killed
someone yeah Paul Newman made a cam yeah
but yeah that and then um so I'm very
that's what I'm here focusing in yeah
and it's a I think I made a I never
think i' do things right but I think I
made a good piece of work and I'm
actually proud to show show it to people
so your material is so great you just
style is great so best case is to go on
to YouTube on your on Bert's Channel
we're going to make sure this drops
right after that would be great so just
go go to the Channel watch the special
it'll make you feel good just
share comment on YouTube different it's
like we didn't do it in a theater and we
didn't do it we did it in a little indie
rock club with like uh in Brooklyn
called the sultan room and it used to be
like a the interesting thing about the
venue is it used to be this Supper Club
in Wisconsin yeah uh and they uh when it
shut down the guys who own this version
of it now went to Wisconsin and bought
the entire bar and moved it into
Brooklyn oh my God yeah yeah and so like
and they they added like an indie rock
venue into the oh man I'm going to be in
New York next week I'm going to just go
see this place yeah yeah come by to I'll
okay yeah my roommate does the booking
that's how I could I could afford it
dude I love it I would love to not say
that when my next special drops that I
have a roommate so please please watch
godam dude I can't wait to see it I me
show that we've done together yeah it's
we have so we were at Mo Tower together
last year yeah remember how I brought
you up yeah I that's why I have that St
Louis story I did it I yeah I pulled it
again but I can't remember who I Pete
Davidson oh yeah no this is way worse
really yeah what so burp produced a
special and part of the marketing we've
been doing is like I plug it at the end
of all this you know basketball arena
shows yeah huge bird shows yeah and we
were in St Louis and we played the blues
Arena oh the the Scott Trade Center
Savage Center what it's 15,000 people
and CA is hosting the show he's the best
love him so much I'll see him next week
too and he goes uh he goes what do you
want me to say when I bring you up and I
go I just tell him I'm Tom sigura
and oh my God why would you dude he had
me bring him up in
Austin at Cap City as Pete Davidson and
I go you want me to sell it and you go
sell sell the [__] out
of I sold it so people had their cameras
out oh so so now but doing this and you
come out and what do you say because
it's also very plausible yes and
some to us right that's what I'm saying
scheduling to us we know how
would say with the connected world we
have now you can find out where anyone
is he likes digging out he likes getting
out there and having to dig out of it
like digging out I got a little bit of a
punishment Vibe I think yes I said
looked at me and he goes you really want
me to do this and Mark Smalls who I love
loves Mark uh he goes no I'm going to
walk out with a note I'll hand it to you
no and gu who show up yeah yeah and my
God this kind of like guess who's here
are you you serious and Mark goes yeah
he's here and C like goes guys he's
official he's the other bear and like
all goes crazy screaming nuts like out
of their [__] minds God and like and
like he's like you know I'm from your
mom's house and they're and he's like I
need that St Louis and I'm behind the
Monitor and lit this time I was like
they're so loud I was like this truly
might have been the worst mistake shame
and I come out you're like eating the
hottest chip in the world and as it's
going down you're like oh that was a
mistake like yeah I have
diarrhea both cases smelling it I have
diarrhea in both instances and I come
out and they're all
like uh 10% were like all right that was
pretty funny but yeah 10% not as soon as
I got out you can hear like I posted the
footage of it the other day you can hear
this woman just go well [__] you too oh
my God and it's like the moment
the moment on singled out when the two
people face each other you just see the
disappointment on one of their eyes like
they were and then I had to like they
were booing like and I had to lean in
and I like just made fun of the arch for
5 minutes oh my God what can you do it
felt good the real problem is it feels
good the biggest audience of your career
the one thing they should know is your
name yeah so that so it was not Tom
saguro is what they call me now that's
so funny such a ball so that so now from
now when you get introduced on Bird
stories you you have them say this next
comic is not Tom sigura yeah yeah but he
is Shane Tor I mean you got that would
be a very fun way to like get the stick
in the I remember the last part I'm so
impressed that you so you know I think
this is the type of thing that I think
comedians we are so precious about every
moment and opportunity because
opportunities are rare and fleeting and
whatnot I think we have to be a little
more like who gives a [__] I want to
enjoy it more like I don't SP I don't
play loose play loose do you guys feel
that way when you're like you have a big
moment in comedy you're like did I and
you look back at it like a day later
like I didn't even enjoy it I was too
busy trying to nail it 100% late night
sets on television are just four minutes
you get four minutes you're like and
it's like someone once told us I forgot
who it was and you guys doing the tan
like like timing like WRA their heads
around just seeing two people do it they
come like it's a very traditional
vehicle we see what standup looks like
you got to have fun who did you said
somebody said Rick Fox was talking about
I think Chris Paul and was saying why
has Chris Paul not won a a champion
championship and Rick Fox was like you
play golf and we're like yeah he's like
how do you hold the golf club and we're
like like this he's like in your
fingertips yeah he's like he holds it
like this and he's so tight and he and
it's so important for him in a way that
to get one that he's now makes it that
he's not having fun he's not loose and
he's not enjoying what you did just
scrambled the whole thing it took it
took the air out of the out of the
tension of having to do well created a
new tension new tension I'm not going to
do worse than
that he your first line well we're at
the
bottom only one way well let's see I
know was going to have a better set than
me everyone else there's the there's the
top of the arch your opening line is
your welcome Bert you're welcome dude
that's amazing I love ball
in okay this is wonderful although that
could have been I'm so glad you're here
for it sending by Douglas Roberts at
Doug r25 I believe that's the first time
for first
time welcome to town here's the headline
runchy alcohol fueled Taco Bell party
included open sex lawsuit claims this a
Taco Bell
c talk about Cantina for sure has to be
a Cantina has to be hold on sex ranchy
rch Ranch alcohol fueled Taco Bell party
included open sex lawsuit
claims a former Los Angeles that's a new
way to make salsa I guess it is a former
Los this story is so a former Los
Angeles area Taco Bell employee is suing
the company oh and a franchise owner
after she claims a Christmas party at
the fast food restaurant descended into
a drunken mess that included open sex to
me that is exactly what a Taco Bell
Christmas party should Taco Bell has a
Christmas party that's truly corporate
this is just the location this is one
dude you better be you better be you
better be having sex on top of a mound
you to a restaurant employee or bar
employee Christmas
party I've been so they are cuz I worked
in restaurants and bars they are insane
they are in fuckinge and they are
restaurants are already if you think
comedy is incestuous work in a
restaurant like waiting is such a good
movie yeah in the sense that it is like
accurate yeah it is the amount
of waitresses I have had sex with that
my friends have had sex with that we've
all had sex this is like not a dog like
not at all all those waitresses also the
amount of waiters I've and Barts I've
had sex with it goes both ways it's like
it's the city of gamorra with cheese
sticks and it's fing yes and you know
what happens a lot in La bars will trade
so so there was not like employees to
work the parties not like they like
these are our hottest waiters no the a
friend of mine worked at a bar in
Brentwood and so they did a Christmas
party trade with Jones on Santa Monica
so like you so they go there and
everything is free and then they Jones
pick a date to go to their bar and
everything it's a it's like a Monday or
Tuesday obviously yes but it is it's
like right cuz they're like work you
work you're working so hard you're not
making a ton of money you're around
other people having fun You' worked the
holiday you work Fray now it's your
ready to rip if you work those parties
you clean up finances yeah that's like
that is your Chas that's your Christmas
bonus nobody who's ever worked at a
restaurant treats other restaurant
workers like [__] they just know they
always treat people but this is a Taco
Bell having a Christmas party barely a
restaurant nobody can I quote Jeff Ty's
great joke about the Taco Bell Cantina
his joke was uh they serve alcohol at
the Taco Bell Cantina like you're not
supposed to get drunk at a Taco Bell
you're supposed to drive drunk to a Taco
Bell I got drunk at a I've gotten drunk
at a Chipotle simple neat you do you
ever do Margarita at a Chipotle no I've
gotten hammered at a come on Chicago I
got I did do I got shitfaced and did
comedy at an Applebees that's God I
thought he was going to say you were
like did you ever do get margar do uh
Margaritas at a Chipotle and I thought
Shane was going to be like no but I did
heroin at a
Houston you ever you ever bang H init a
Ruby
Tuesdays Alana betom filed her lawsuit
last week in Los Angeles Superior Court
in the suit she alleges that her
supervisor invited her to the December
18th 2022 party at the San Pedro Taco
Bell at which she worked okay she was
encouraged to bring food for a potluck
style buffet and her contribution
was a bowl of guacamole there you go
that's not enough also you're bringing
sand to the beach that's
right that's well put maybe you're
bringing the beach to sand that's true
too yeah hers is probably better hers
was authentic guacamole not something
youo out a tube in the back you got a
[__] gun you going to tell me what you
did is more efficient than what we do
you talk about the [__] the guac I'm
just saying if you're bringing guacamole
to the Taco Bell Christmas party yeah no
matter what happens at the party you
aren't gonna fit in no it isn't gonna be
your party this is not a well you
shouldn't have been dressed that way
kind of thing but this is pretty dumb
hey guys hey guys guess what Alana
brought uh more the thing that's in all
your shirts and you can't get out of the
smell your cow that's
right once she arrived once she arrived
betom quote discovered that her
supervisor covered the windows of the
restaurant with wrapping paper okay
that's when you know like are we now in
a cult and also covered the cameras for
the lobby and the inside of the
restaurant this is where I'm like this
is the beginning of
Blade this is like are we now all going
to cut our dicks off what's happening
right cover the cameras cover the
cameras cover the camer you go in
anywhere and you look around and the
cameras are covered and you aren't part
of why they are covered like you didn't
have a hand in that leave leave get out
very yeah not this is what Eyes Wide
Shut should have been she claims her
supervisor provided alcohol to staffers
several of whom were over served no [__]
it's a Christmas party anywhere
andell not even we haven't I think it's
just a straight up Taco Bell oh this is
okay this is not a c they brought the
Cantina to the regular Taco they turned
it into a Cana around midnight after bom
had stepped outside for a short time
look again I don't want a victim blame
no but get out you've been there too
long what leave this is the family that
won't leave the haunted house get out
this is also the thing of like just can
you imagine your your Christmas party at
work being interrupted by like drunk
people just being like the [__]
clothes today
like the amount of people going through
the that had to Feel So Satisfied people
drive be like yeah or people just going
through the drivethru screaming at it
the and they're like I don't have do
rattling yeah we just C
twists God the worst midnight in the
history
of it's just cinnamon air uh after
around midnight after bom had stepped
outside for a short time she walked back
into the restaurant and saw a coworker
quote having sex with his wife in front
of everyone at the party by the way his
wife I don't have he loves her she loves
him he loves her holidays this was part
of their vows this was in their vows I
to love you in sickness and health and
to have sex with you in front of
everyone at a taco about yeah like
Christmas party tell me you're you
haven't had sex at a fast food
established in front of your coworkers
come on they have like a little list
like guys we got a Burger King and a
Wendy's and then we're done
we've already hit McDonald's we've
already hit in- and out literally in-
and out the coworkers in and out every
time we just can't seem to nail a
custers like we're never in New
Hampshire we got to go to Biscuitville
guys we got to go to North Carolina and
then take it on down never happen out of
Bojangles it's a fine establish it's
more Jangles so she goes in her
cooworker is having sex with his wife in
front of everyone at the party the
co-worker's wife B claims was also
kissing her female manager and another
female Co worker at the same time we
call that overtime that's a triple stuff
burrito is what that is it's called
marrying your can I just say there's
never I've never been in any Taco Bell
where there were three employees I
wanted to have sex with I
mean I'm whatever man whatever like
maybe you like you know him so maybe you
get to know the person but just on the
Cardinal like I want that right the only
thing I'm looking at in a Taco Bell is
the menu listen Dan I'm happy with I'm
fine with her having sex with her
husband in front of everybody even
kissing the night manager and another
person I don't like the fact that she
called one of the other employees her
little gordita I you didn't like that I
that's where I draw the line I'm just
impressed we've gotten this far into the
story and you haven't brought up burning
man
that's used to get a lot Wilder but now
that we have breakfast I have to be up
dude the the Christmas party of Taco
Bell is so commercial now man it's not
like the or us like the OR at Burning
Man shoot guns back in the day okay the
coworker's uh wife uh says best okay she
was kissing two people at once get
railed shocked disgusted and outraged
those are quotes bom alleges that she
first ran out of the restaurant but then
had to go back inside to retrieve her
guacamole
bowl at this point you leave at this
point people are like in the bowl naked
she's like can I can I just get this off
your naked ass spank me with this bowl
on my butt yeah you can just move your
testicles really quick only to find that
her manager and the other coworker were
involved in a sexual no hold on only to
find that her manager and the other
coworker involved in the sexual
encounter were now vomiting oh in oh God
it got to be oh one threw up in the
trash while the other one vomited into
her guacamole
Bowl I told you this story this story
starts with a bang and then it just
keeps delivering this this is the first
two rounds of Haggler her just throwing
punches like lud
the [__] out you got cameras covered
Christmas present Windows Taco Bell
closed down multiple sex partners guac I
watch parasite and they show the water
running down the stairs of course it was
in the guacamole pole this might not be
the alcohol this might be just the food
to talko Bell Dan it might be guacamole
Dan if if any of us were there I would
any of us were there and then saw
someone threw up throw up in the
guacamole Bowl each of us would have
made this exact jug be like now it looks
like Taco Bell guacamole
did I get some of that wrap it up in
aino the cars are backing up put it in a
chalupa we got it back up oh they're
they're vomiting she goes back in
they're vomiting into her guacamole B
says she reported the incident to Taco
Bell Human Resources why they have one
and Alvarado Restaurant Group the
Colorado based franchisee the manager
and other co-workers involved in the
sexual encounter Alo what's it what's
the franchise Alvar group Alvarado
Restaurant Group the Colorado based
franchisee I thought someone's name was
El
Dorado why not everyone in the everyone
in the Alvarado Restaurant Group in
Colorado drives in El
Dorado
yes uh the manager and the co-workers
involved in the sexual encounter were
fired sure after their termination bom
alleges that where would you ever get
another job like that I don't know those
were the good
old with that party after the
termination bom alleges that she was
threatened and had her car window
Shattered by someone associated with her
former co-workers this goes deep guys
it's deep dude deep you can't you can't
like ring the bell on these people you
can't blow the whistle on these people
while they're blowing each other how
lonely is your life if you take away a
Taco Bell employee Christmas party and
then you you got to eat that you're
resulting to witness intimidation you
got to eat that you or you got to walk
back in and be like you puked in my bowl
you clean it out you bring it to me and
I won't say a word to anyone something
like that that you can't call also if
you do get fired you can't then go well
we should go [__] with that girl's car
because what did you think would happen
you rode the rail and you fell off on
the wrong side which store is this is in
Los Angeles
yes down by Long Beach down by Long
Beach go we we should go and app in our
interview be like what's the Christmas
party situation look we're in the season
look I'm I wore a Santa hat I'm a jolly
guy I want the J until December 24th
it's the it is the season of giving and
receiving hello I don't TR I think I
could just I figured out how to throw
[__] in a tortilla Taco Bell and the
franchisee quote did nothing about these
threats what do you want them to do
about it they already fired the people
dude this the best thing ever happen
instead told her they were transferring
her to a new location rather than
disciplining the employees who
threatened her like she's a Catholic
priest she's well they don't know they
can't prove that they threatened her so
they're like we don't want you to get
fired we don't want you to if these
people are bad we're going to move you
but in in a positive way move for
hopefully yeah we're going to take you
to Pal or move them maybe yeah I don't
know her life be UPR she's got she
eventually quit and alleges that she
quote has suffered actual consequential
and incidental Financial losses what and
that Taco Bell violated
anti-discrimination law I everybody was
getting to have sex what are you talking
about this is indiscriminate sex KTLA KT
reached out to Taco Bell and the
Alvarado Restaurant Group for comment
none was given dang this is our towards
the Night Before Christmas this is the
greatest this is dumb people's town the
night before christas all through the
house everyone and all through the
guacamole bowl no it was the night
before Christmas and all through the
Bell not a creature was stirring
everyone was drunk as hell there
go is that
it Story number two we have one more
segment it'll be a quick one we're going
to find
out we're going to find out what Dan's
doing and then we will take us on home
with the great Shane Torres whose
special is called one more time the
blue-eyed Mexican the blueeyed Mexican
you're never going to forget that it's D
people town with Shane Tes we'll be
right
[Music]
back people hey guys want to talk to you
about our friends at farity not a day
goes by that I don't wear a piece of
farity clothing yesterday I was wearing
their comfortable uh chos that were so
good with the drawring that was amazing
I'm wearing the sweatpants
Dan I that was that was our gift to you
one year we like you travel all sweater
shirt Legend sweater shirt and Legend
sweatpants they're nice they got their
button-ups I got a nice short sleeve
button up that I rocked well the
summertime stuff I have every flowered
shirt that they own and I have the
sweatshirt with the sun on it I have the
rugby shirt that I wear all their stuff
is great and usually when I'm wearing a
faity someone comes up to you they're
like what is that where is that how do I
get that the Doug good feather stuff
that they have which is like the Native
American print stuff is just I I wear it
on stage I wear it when we do stuff on
TV I love it so much they feel like a
day at the beach does it all of that
stuff really does I mean the legend
sweaters are really my favorite I think
I have five or six of those the legend
sweater flannels so it's it looks like a
flannel on the outside stret stretchy
feels comfortable it's the best feeling
in the world they're great clothes to
traveling they're great clothes that
look nice but then third little secret
is that you're actually comfortable like
you're in and they're run by great
people who actually care about their
customers and care about the planet and
just care about putting good things on
good people that about you guys because
for our listeners and listeners of the
show faity is giving all Dum people Town
listeners an amazing deal 20% off your
order head to faity brand.com DPT use
the code DPT a checkout we really do
love it's a holiday season this is the
time get gifts for people use the the
discount code and you're all gold here's
what it is f a hty brand.com
DPT hey gang it is crazy times these
times that we live in right now we're
all as busy as can be and sometimes it's
hard to organize all the things you're
doing you miss phone calls you miss Zoom
meetings because you're not organized
you're like wait this has happened to me
so many times we have so many things
going on as Comedians and podcasters and
actors all the things we have going on
I'm sure you're just as busy you need a
place something that can sort of
synthesize all the calendar events you
get for holiday parties and meetings and
all this stuff you need one place for
that yeah you do and the Skylight
calendar is a smart touchscreen calendar
and organizer for all your chores
groceries and to-dos it automatically
syncs all of the different digital
calendars and events that your family
uses and shows them all together in one
beautiful touchscreen display Skylight
calendar is the best way to give your
family peace of mind and to enjoy the
things that matter most 100%
satisfaction guaranteed if you don't
love the Skylight calendar you'll
receive a full refund they offer 120-day
money back guarantee up and free returns
and when you put it in your personal
life you're probably not going to return
it cuz you'll love it right you won't
it's improved my life and it's helped
our whole family get on the same page
which is so beautiful first of all
really easy to sync other calendar to
get on top of it really easy to use the
free app to put events in you can just
touch the screen and put events in it
sits a thing that says dinner planning
grocery list and it does a daily weather
supplay or weather weather display based
on where your event is taking place so
you can check the weather on where
you're going to be right there on the
calendar it's so good and everybody has
a color in my family that represents
what they're doing my 9-year-old
daughter loves to see how many things
she has going she likes to be in
competition with her brother she likes
it sometimes she has more events than he
does I love it it helps all get on the
same page it's actually helped our
relationship as a family cuz we know
what we're doing we love to be organized
and for our special as a special thing
for our listeners our offer for
listeners you get $15 off your purchase
of a skylight calendar when you go to
Skylight cal.com DPT that's $15 off your
purchase of a skylight calendar just go
to Skylight cal.com DPT Dan that's SK y
l i g HT C A l.com
DPT sck around make a sound there's
Town hey gang welcome back I'm going to
take us home with one final story that
is insanity have any Daniel's got some
stuff happening I do uh December 15th my
movie wine club is out you can watch it
on streaming services I uh we're going
to make sure this drops right around
that time that's great go check it out
if you go to wine club movie I believe
on Instagram you can uh get an
opportunity there to be uh at the
screening the first La Premiere the
first time I will watch it with a whole
big group of people that's on January
17th and then I am headlining yeah yeah
come hang out
yes I I would sincerely love that uh
December 14th I'm headlining Cap City
comedy so come on out to that my buddy
Pete Davidson might be there with me as
well and what else for me oh I think I'm
going to be doing a weekend in DC in
February but everything is up at Daniel
vk.com because there's more rose gold
tour dates being announced until I drop
the special in probably April thanks to
all Dan thanks to Green Ivy creative who
uh helped me rebuild my website they're
they're aw and they heard this and you
should go check them out PL for them
shout out to Green Ivy creative all
right we got another story sent in by
our good one a great one carlen mcder at
car okay here's the I'm not going to
give the amount but this is this is the
the headline holiday moans holiday moans
holiday Christmas Vacation I booked a
romantic certain amount of pounds
holiday to Mexico but it was ruined by
porn on the hotel TV what this how's
that Ru does this sound like something
we did this just happened to me do you
want to guess which city uh Las Vegas no
Portland St
Lewis I was in the hotel and I'm sitting
there a chair in a room with Andrew
Young Blood on the road and I turn the
channel and it is straight up porn and I
don't do anything and Andrew finally
like looks Up's like what is it what is
it you ordered this I go no I didn't
order goes you ordered this there's no
way this is on the TV I go dude we're in
St Louis this is on the TV Dude local TV
access we're in the arch baby it was
full on this gu is people could still
order pornography on I don't know I
didn't order it was so much free stuff
on your computer sound a lot like that
guy who had back problems tells me you
don't have a laptop I I I'll pay for my
point Frank Butler not Fon but Frank
Butler how old do you think Frank is 70
Frank Butler 70 how old I mean there's
no Frank Butler under 20 right You no
Frank is a Frank is a Frank Butler Frank
is a soldier's name girls a Frank War 70
how old is he a plumber Frank Butler and
he's pissed and he wants to sh he's mad
about porn 63 66 years old okay what do
you think I'm going to say First Gulf
War age whatever like
80 58 58 okay all right uh Frank Butler
you almost said it Dan 63 years old 63
years old oh I said 70 forked out out a
lot of money for a two we day at a
festar Mexican hotel with his girlfriend
an no an no whenever whenever who this
whenever he switched on the Telly he was
confronted by disgusting sex acts and
hardcore ROM stand this is your thing
how much TV are you watching on a trip
to Mexico you loser it's a romantic
getaway right I'm going to let it be the
I'm going to read learn something I'm
going to read the next phrase and you're
going to be like I've never heard this
before entire life when describing
someone's profession that he forly had
okay the former submarine engineer what
wow was he in charge of the
submersible no this is Navy and that is
a lot of security CS to be honest so
said we got there and the hotel was fine
the food was a bit Bland and wait why
are we bringing this up when it's
a it was 3 days in and I decided to turn
on the TV to watch the news yeah right
he recalled after accessing the menu
when we clicked it on the TV it went
straight to porn it was fullon I thought
oh my God that is disgusting chill out
right hey I have a big solution for this
it's very hard to do and I feel bad
telling him this cuz it takes too much
effort need 63 turn the channel turn or
turn it off I also feel like this guy is
not a former submarine engineer already
like oh yeah yeah yeah he's got a Frank
duk's level of Lying by way maybe this
is the way they do the news in Mexico we
don't know yeah it's like you're you're
acting it out the Naked News The Naked
News are like things in Waka are [__]
yeah yeah
okay
exactly he even filmed he even filmed
the turning on process so he could later
masturbate to it no no I'm sorry to
prove to others that he did not select
the smut himself that's so funny cuz I
filmed it too he filmed what if you what
if what if the only way you could get
off is to film this guy filming the oh
my God he said can you imagine if I bar
mirror that keeps going and so he said
can you imagine if I took my partner's
mom here who is how old how old's the
partner's mom partner's mom
8686 91 what do you think I'm saying
like 86 too okay 83 years old okay there
hold on and wanted to watch the news and
that came up now he says this he kind of
goes a little twitch a little turn this
is such a great quote don't get me wrong
I worked with bles in the dockyards for
40 years so now he's trying to do his
with a wire I've seen it all myself have
you have you seen it all if you seen it
all yourself why did this bother what
trying to get money off he's like but it
ruined my holiday I don't want to go to
a five star and be confronted with that
why not just stay in your house stay in
your house stay in house extra star is a
porn star that's it hey so if you go I
love that was the final I don't want to
be confronted with that and the article
there by way I've seen everything that a
man could do with a with an so he's not
is he suing them
he's oh you didn't say the number at the
top oh yeah oh yeah he's not suing but
he just complained about it how it was
how much money how much did he spend
pound in pounds on the hotel on the
hotel I know that I'm a very like
sexually liberal person I feel like we
all are we're like do your thing don't
hurt anybody be nice make sure it's
consensual and have fun but the B how
much money youd be
pissed 2,000 lb 2,000 lb what do you
think uh for how many days couple days
three days uh 25 00 lb what do you
think festar Mexican Hotel 800 4500 okay
I think it needed to be enough for him
to be get your answers in Towes
blue-eyed Mexican he's right here and
watch the special it's out Daniel come
see uh the the wine club which comes out
on the 17th 15th 15th sorry 15 15th uh I
love you guys thank you we love all of
our townies you guys are the best as we
end dur this holiday season I will say
that Frank Butler 63-year old frank
Butler spent 5,000 pounds
on you're going to the Showcase how much
how much fun is this show buddy I love
it I have a [__] blast here I swear a
lot I'm realizing iar man dude you're
the best I love that you're here on the
show shant friend of the family and uh
oh [__] we got to get back to work guys
[Music]
by